Your support of Bitcoin puts you
in the same category as
the framers of the Constitution.
Bitcoin is special.
Bitcoin
is the future.
Bitcoin will undermine their ability
to control us.
It has all the trappings of a
religion.
Those who are not getting into
Bitcoin now, it's because their DNA
was not meant to survive.
FTX is the safest and easiest way to
buy and sell crypto.
Sam Bankman-Fried is in federal
court right now for his arraignment.
The collapse of FTX gave the
Biden admin a perceived moral
license to go after crypto
in this aggressive way.
And the governments aren't exactly
going to let us walk in the front
door with this new open source money
called Bitcoin.
Everything you're seeing now we've
seen before, there's nothing new.
It is just typical Bitcoin.
15 years after Satoshi Nakamoto
dropped a nine page white paper on
an obscure email list sketching out
an idea for a new peer-to-peer
digital currency, Bitcoin has become
a global phenomenon, and nowhere is
its pomp and promise more on display
than at the blockbuster annual
conference put on by Bitcoin
Magazine here in Miami Beach.
But it's also had a disappointing
couple of years.
Bitcoin was supposed to be an
inflation hedge, but after the Fed
fired up its money printer during
the pandemic, the dollar lost value
and Bitcoin went in the same
direction. Bitcoin was supposed to
be a way to transfer money from one
party to another without going
through a financial institution, to
quote Satoshi.
But 15 years later, a lot of
users are still trusting regulated
financial institutions to manage
their holdings.
Bitcoin was supposed to be above
politics, but the community around
it has seen bitter infighting.
Just saying that's how not how you
use Bitcoin, though.
That's not how you use it.
You should use Bitcoin in this
particular way.
And some worry that Bitcoiners
intolerance of dissenting ideas
has turned it into something akin to
a religion or a cult.
And yet the bitcoiners we talked to
in Miami seemed convinced that its
value proposition as a decentralized
money that governments can't censor
or destroy is as strong as ever.
Are Bitcoin's troubles a sign
that the project is failing, or just
the inevitable bumps on an upward
trajectory which will one day result
in monetary freedom for the entire
world?
Attendance here at one of the
largest Bitcoin conferences in the
world
is down by more than half amid this
so-called crypto winter.
I think if you were to compare like
last year's conference to this
year's one,
Very noticeable dramatic difference.
I'm not a fan of the
mania bull run phases
because of the type of people
that it attracts.
You might call them the tourists or
the larpers or in many cases
the scammers.
There is a big chunk of crypto
that needs to burn on a raging
funeral pyre.
There were criminals,
scammers, grifters, overleveraged
business models that should never
have been implemented.
FTX has arrived in 305.
So I just got one question.
You in, Miami?
Just a few miles away from this
year's conference is the Miami
Heat's home court, formerly called
FTX Arena after the crypto platform
paid $135 million
for the naming rights back in 2021.
In January, when FTX collapsed
into bankruptcy and its founder, Sam
Bankman-Fried, was arrested for
alleged fraud, the signage was
removed. Bitcoiners believe that any
cryptocurrency other than Satoshi's
original creation should be referred
to as a shitcoin and that the crypto
industry is a cargo cult run
by scammers who have the mainstream
media and much of Silicon Valley
fooled. Exhibit A, Sam
Bankman-Fried.
He's a criminal. He should go to
jail. People who conflate what they
did with Bitcoin have got it
entirely wrong.
The way I like to describe the
crypto industry and blockchain
is it's an arbitrage on the trend.
It's sad and it's discussing.
It's got to stop.
Bitcoiners also see the FTX
collapse as a reminder that you
can't trust bankers or tech founder
media darlings like Bankman-Fried
to take care of your savings,
whether they're outright scammers or
not. Banks must be trusted to hold
our money and transfer it
electronically, but they lend it
out in waves of credit bubbles with
barely a fraction in reserve,
Satoshi wrote in 2009.
The message is, trust nobody
and become your own bank, which
Bitcoin makes possible.
I think it just shows that, like
these large centralized institutions
are always going to be at risk.
So the ethos of Bitcoin is not about
putting all of your money into a
giant centralized custodian.
So like, none of that would have
happened in TradFi because everyone
would have been bolstered, everyone
would have been bailed out.
But in crypto, the bad actors were
allowed to implode publicly and
people got hurt.
But that overall is just the
immune system for crypto showing
itself.
Another reason to be your own bank
is to avoid financial censorship
so that everyone from third world
dictators to DC regulators
is prevented from telling you how
you should spend your money.
The fall of FTX precipitated
a crackdown in Washington that was
meant to send a very strong
anti-crypto message, in the words
of former Congressman Barney Frank.
We don't need more digital currency.
We already have digital currency.
It's called the US Dollar.
FTX certainly gave them political
cover to do this.
Then they opened up the toolkit and
they went to their favorite
tool, which is politicizing
the instruments of finance.
Nick Carter is a writer and crypto
investor who coined the phrase
Operation Choke Point 2.0,
a reference to the Obama era policy
of bullying banks into denying
accounts to payday lenders,
pornographers, firearms dealers,
strippers, and other fully legal
industries that regulators would
rather see disappear.
So again, a perfectly legal
industry in the US that's
being targeted through the
bank regulatory apparatus.
It really kicked off this
year in January.
It involved virtually every
financial regulatory agency,
in particular the bank regulators.
And the objective was to stymie the
legal crypto industry in the US,
not through any lawful mechanism,
but through insinuations,
through threats.
Operation Choke Point 1.0 was
carried out by the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau, which
was the brainchild of Elizabeth
Warren, and now she's become the
Senate's most vocal Bitcoin critic.
If I buy Bitcoin, am I buying a
share of stock or am
I buying a pork belly?
Or are you buying air?
Rogue nations, oligarchs, drug
lords and human traffickers are
using digital assets to launder
billions in stolen funds,
evade sanctions, and finance
terrorism, Warren said last
year when promoting a bill that
would extend the state's power to
surveil people's finances.
Crypto is helping fund the fentanyl
trade, and we have the power
to shut that down.
If I were Elizabeth Warren, what
would you say to me?
First of all, I'd shake your hand.
I would say, hi, it's really good to
meet you.
I would also say you are
purposely misinformed about crypto.
She doesn't have Bitcoin.
She doesn't understand energy.
She's part of the elite.
She's part of the corrupt political
structure in the U.S.
and she's anti-human.
She's anti-freedom.
I've been trying to clean up this
industry
for a while because I firmly
believe that there are
affronts to private property rights.
Caitlin Long, who spent 22 years
in corporate finance, is the founder
of Custodial, which she hopes will
become America's first Bitcoin bank.
It's designed to be the antithesis
of the company run by Bankman-Fried,
whom Long clashed with on stage
at the same Bitcoin conference back
in 2021.
Satoshi gave us money
that isn't debt.
I like to use the phrase, a fool
and their leveraged Bitcoin are soon
parted.
Sam, do you agree?
Not with a lot of it.
I
guess that's not shocking.
FTX allegedly squandered its
customers holdings.
Custodia, by contrast, plans
to go much further than even a
regulated retail bank by keeping
108% of its customers
cash in Bitcoin on hand at
all times.
Thus, it won't have any need for
federal deposit insurance.
Look, you can take the position
leverage is bad.
It's not a crazy thing to think.
However, I think you probably also
have to be willing
to sacrifice more than most people
realize in order to get there.
I think you have had to sacrifice
the majority of the growth that the
industry has had to date.
And he and I were arguing over
whether leverage was good.
Leverage is never good
in crypto, period.
Anything that is circulation credit
that goes above one times
leverage, right?
That is creating claims
to the underlying out of thin
air. It is fractional reserve
banking and we are fundamentally
committed to not doing that.
All of those crypto lenders I knew
were going to fail. Why?
Because there's a finite number of
bitcoin.
All you're doing is creating
fractional reserve Bitcoin
and that's all going to come
back to haunt you when inevitably
there's going to be a price
correction and everybody wants the
real thing.
Yet the Federal Reserve rejected
Custodia's application to become
a member of its network on the
grounds that its, quote,
crypto activities are highly likely
to be inconsistent with safe and
sound banking practices.
So the crypto industry was proposing
a solution to the inherent
instability of the banking sector,
and yet that solution was denied
because the Federal Reserve didn't
want to give a crypto focused
bank access to the payment system.
It's extremely perverse.
Long is suing the Federal Reserve
to force it to reconsider, but part
of Satoshi's vision was to create a
system in which regulatory approval
wasn't necessary.
Bitcoin is the first digital
currency you can hold yourself.
So why do we need to trust a third
party middleman at all?
You read the whitepaper.
You read what Satoshi said.
Trusted third parties are security
holes.
Jameson Lopp is a Bitcoin developer
and the co-founder of Casa, which
helps its customers safely
self-custody the secret passwords
or keys necessary to spend their
Bitcoin. If you lose them, the money
is as good as gone.
But if you're not holding them
yourself, are they really yours?
The Bitcoin writer and evangelist
Andreas Antonopoulos coined
a popular saying in the space.
Your keys, your bitcoin.
Not your keys, not your bitcoin.
Your keys, your
bitcoin. Not your keys, not
your bitcoin.
Most people don't want to be their
own bank. But what we're really
saying is like, if you want to have
a level of bank
security, if you want to be able to
operate in such a way that
you don't have to ask permission
from a third party, then
you do have to take on some
responsibility.
Self-custody especially appeals to
Bitcoiners worried about Operation
Choke Point 2.0 and the plight of
the Canadian truckers who occupied
Ottawa last year to protest a
cross-border COVID vaccine mandate.
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
responded to the demonstrators by
using emergency powers to force
financial institutions to freeze
all funds set to support the
cause.
These illegal
blockades and occupations received
disturbing amounts of foreign
funding.
So a group of activists used Bitcoin
as it was meant to be used, getting
about $630,000
worth to the truckers.
Since the funds didn't go through
the traditional banking system, they
were hard to stop.
An activist filmed himself handing
out seed phrases, or the code words
used to access self-custodied
Bitcoin. This grassroots solution
was imperfect, laborious, and
in need of improvement.
But in the end it worked.
A world where most people hold their
own Bitcoin keys would be a world
far more resistant to financial
censorship and surveillance.
But is it really possible?
It's definitely a breach of a
person's privacy,
freezing their bank accounts,
especially if they've committed no
real crimes.
Do you think there's ever a future
where we can get grandmas to
self-custody?
Well, it's definitely possible.
And I can tell you from experience,
we have plenty of people in
their eighties who are clients
of Casa.
The answer lies somewhere in the
middle. I think we will have a
diverse ecosystem and range
of custody and
it doesn't actually necessarily
need to be a binary thing.
It doesn't have to be just trusted
third party or just self-custody.
What really worries me is
if too much of the Bitcoin goes into
too few hands, especially if they're
like regulated companies
that can be easily targeted by
nation states, that is when
Bitcoin itself,
you know, as a network
becomes a bit
more prone to nation
state actions.
And that for many at this conference
is the entire point of Bitcoin.
Effective resistance against
authoritarian government action.
As most of you know, that trucker
strike was a peaceful demonstration
of people who are demanding rights
that are sacred and are
taken for granted for every
American.
Walking around the conference, all
of the elements of the Bitcoiners
creed were on full display, which
Nick Carter says has turned into a
religion. It has its own heroes,
icons, doctrines, saints,
and heretics.
On one hand, having a devoted
following that won't abandon a
project through the rough patches is
a key to long term success.
On the other, fanaticism
leads to poor decision making and
can drive away vital allies.
Certainly not the only secular
religion out there, but it's a
particularly pernicious breed.
Nick Carter was in Miami this year
during the conference, but says he
didn't attend any of the sessions
because of safety concerns.
Much of the community turned on him
when it was revealed that his
investment fund had a stake in
cryptocurrencies other than just
Bitcoin. So he penned a eulogy
for Bitcoin maximalism declaring
that there's an awful sickness
pervading the space.
I have been a full time Bitcoiner
for ten years and I've dedicated my
professional and personal
efforts to the sector tirelessly
that whole time.
And yet, because I'm more of a
Bitcoin moderate a lot of the
hard liner Bitcoiners don't like me,
but I think what we need to realize
is our enemy
is not inward.
We shouldn't be doing this circular
firing squad thing.
Something all Bitcoiners have been
saying for years is there's a big
difference between Bitcoin and
crypto, a distinction that now even
the head of the S.E.C., Gary
Gensler, made when talking about
crypto regulation.
Speaking Monday on CNBC,
Gensler said
that Bitcoin is the only
cryptocurrency that he is prepared
to label publicly as a commodity.
There has been a decent amount
from Bitcoiners, some that I respect
that have essentially been cheering
on government attacking people.
The end game is attacking Bitcoin.
There's an expression in crypto.
Not your keys, not
your
crypto. Bitcoiners should be trying
to win in the free market and
organize Bitcoin such that
it is the most compelling
blockchain, the most credible
one, the most decentralized.
They should not be trying to utilize
the instruments of state power to
suppress their perceived
adversaries.
Bitcoin has
its own merits.
It stands on its own two feet.
We don't need financial regulators
to try and pick and choose which
winners there are.
Jameson Lopp has also been on the
receiving end of Bitcoin maximalist
rage after his company, Casa,
made the business decision to expand
its service to help Ethereum owners
self-custody their holdings.
In 2019, a teenager called
in a SWAT raid on his home because,
according to Lopp, the kid didn't
like his opinion about how the
Bitcoin protocol should function.
In response, Lopp shared a video of
himself firing an AR-15
on Twitter. Then he took
extraordinary steps to make himself
impossible to track down in
meatspace, which was later written
up by the New York Times.
It's a result of social media.
You can instantly
go from being essentially
a nobody with
no one paying attention to you,
to being someone who has
attracted the ire of millions of
people in a matter of moment.
It's similar to sort of political
theater and phenomenon where
you build up your narratives, you
build your audience and you're
following in your community and
in one of the ways that you
create a more cohesive
audience is by having enemies
that you attack in certain
ideological ways.
And so basically that same thing
has unfolded within Bitcoin.
Most of the religious imagery
present at the conference was
shrouded in irony.
But as with so much of digital life,
it was hard to tell where the joke
ended.
I don't believe that there's any
moral status in your
portfolio, and there is
a faction within Bitcoin that
believes that the only moral
asset to hold is Bitcoin itself,
nothing else. Bitcoin religion is
not a universalizing one.
It actually just concentrates
the membership and they become
increasingly radical and
disconnected from the real world.
So if they want to succeed,
they need to find a way to
grow the membership of the Bitcoin
space rather than
impose all these additional
requirements in terms of what it
means to be in Bitcoiner.
As the quasi religious fervor around
Bitcoin has grown, so too
has the potential for a Bitcoin
voting block. Ronald Reagan once
courted the religious right, but in
2023, a parade of once
and future presidential contenders
made the trek down to Miami to
pander to the Bitcoiners.
Former Congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard
showed up.
Once we give up our economic
autonomy, we give up
our freedom.
Along with longshot presidential
candidate Vivek Ramaswamy.
Freedom of speech and freedom
of money are two sides
of the same coin.
Perhaps nobody better captured the
mood, though, than, Democratic
presidential candidate Robert F.
Kennedy Jr, who in his keynote
speech repeated the anti-elite
populist messaging that is central
to the Bitcoin creed.
Control over the public starts
perhaps as a means,
but it always becomes
an end through exercising
perfect control over society.
Bitcoin is a bulwark
against precisely
this kind of government and
corporate expansion and intrusion.
Like Robert Kennedy, basically what
he's saying with that was like
government is not your friend.
An art gallery at the conference
displayed work demonizing Bill
Gates, Anthony Fauci, and the World
Economic Forum's Klaus Schwab.
What do you think about Klaus Schwab?
Truthfully, I don't think it's
messed up anywhere near enough.
You know, there are certainly a lot
of people who get turned off by
some of the vitriol,
whereas other people get interested
and sucked into it.
But if anything, I think it
may be overblown that the vast
majority of people who use Bitcoin
don't know about any of that.
They just see Bitcoin as a thing
that they're using.
It's not something
that they have adopted from a
cultural standpoint.
It's just a tool that they have
adopted because of the properties
of Bitcoin.
What's the purpose of Bitcoin?
To not be with the government.
We should just be focusing on, you
know, what our Bitcoin strengths,
which is like peer to peer
transactions,
non-KYC transactions and that's
what I'm interested in.
What is Bitcoin?
To me it's money.
In the original whitepaper, Satoshi
described Bitcoin as a peer to peer
electronic cash system.
15 years later, it still isn't
widely used as a medium of exchange.
At first its limitations were
technical. The network can't process
more than about 7 to 10 transactions
per second.
But a decentralized payment
technology called the Lightning
Network is endlessly scalable
and has made paying for a cup of
coffee with Bitcoin fairly seamless,
though not a lot of people are doing
it yet.
I have 100% conviction.
I mean, there's there's zero doubt.
It's just a question of, you
know, at what pace global adoption
will take place. Chris Hunter
founded Bitcoin Beach Wallet, a
lightning based payment software
that launched in El Salvador, whose
president, Nayib Bukele, is
another politician who has
capitalized on his association with
the Bitcoin community.
He announced at the 2021 conference
that El Salvador would be first in
the world to adopt Bitcoin as legal
currency.
It was 90 days from the announcement
here in Miami two years ago when
they were going to make Bitcoin
legal tender.
Only 90 days later, on September 7,
2021, did they actually
launch the implementation with
their Chivo Wallet, which was the
government issued wallet gifted to
every citizen.
Nobody could manage a 90
day implementation like that
properly. And so there was
understandably technical missteps,
and that was quite unfortunate
because, you know, the average
person in El Salvador or anywhere
around the world doesn't really
understand Bitcoin.
Salvadorans prefer to hold
and spend the U.S.
dollar, which, despite the recent
spike in inflation, still has a much
more stable value than Bitcoin.
In terms of adopting Bitcoin as
legal tender, what really matters
is do we get bitcoin in
the hands of people?
Do they use it as everyday money?
And that's what's going to make the
difference in terms of whether
Bitcoin is widely used or not.
So will Bitcoin ever become a
commonly accepted medium of
exchange?
That's partly a bet that
technologies like the Lightning
Network will continue making it
easier and easier to use.
And it's also a bet against the
dollar as exploding U.S.
debt puts increasing pressure on
the Federal Reserve to inflate the
money supply.
The only way that Bitcoin is going
to move forward and get
mass adoption is through bottom
up grassroots movements.
Bitcoin has been eulogized
repeatedly by journalists in the
mainstream media, and yet it
has always come back, surviving
exchange collapses, bitter
infighting and government
antagonism.
The access to the payment system
should be something that is neutral,
apolitical.
It should be a common resource,
right.
And right now, barriers
are being inserted into access
to payments and banking, and
it's becoming much more a question
of do you have political favor
as an industry.
And that's just not the way it
should be in this country.
You know, there is a saying which is
Bitcoin is for enemies.
This is really supposed to be a
neutral technology and platform
where anyone who follows the rules
can use it regardless of if
anyone else disagrees with who they
are and what they're doing.
As the human drama unfolds,
this decentralized, borderless,
censorship resistant software
network continues to function
just as Satoshi envisioned.